- Hi, I'm Karl Dunn
and this is my home forge
in Greenville, South Carolina.
This is my main grinder here,
uh, big vise there,
all the tools and stuff
right there.
Keep all my belts
on a, uh, rolling cart
so I can get at them
whenever I need to.
Here, this is my pride and joy.
This was my grandfather's
anvil.
It gives me a lot of pride
to use this.
This is my main forge,
uh, the big one.
Um, I've had it six months
or so.
Uh, this is the one
that I started with.
Little bit smaller--more of
a knife maker, horseshoe forge.
- Hi, I'm Derick.
Welcome to Damselfly Forge.
Let me give you
a little bit of a tour.
This is the beast.
It's a, uh--it's a drop hammer.
It drops the hammer
once a second.
It comes with appropriate
warnings.
[laughs]
Let's take a step inside.
♪ ♪
First thing, right inside
the shop is my punch press.
This particular machine
was built in 1946.
I fully restored it.
This is actually what I use
to punch the holes
for pickets for fences.
♪ ♪
This is my anvil I use
every day.
This used to shoe horses
in New York City
back in the early 1800s.
And now it is used every day
inside my shop.
- Got my old coal forge
over there and a bag of coal.
Didn't know if I was gonna be
doing some coal work
on this challenge.
Up there, that's my favorite
saying in the world.
Uh, do is greater than say.
Anybody can say something,
but the people that do it,
those are the ones
you gotta look out for.
So that's pretty much
Karl's forge
in Greenville, South Carolina.
- So these are some examples
of ornamental pieces
I'm currently working on.
I made these,
and I added to the form
for my own uses, but these
were practice pieces
to get ready to--
to do this job.
This is my finish room
and machine room.
Uh, of course,
I've got my milling machine.
This is--this is a glorious,
wonderful thing.
Before I built this shop,
I had a nonelectric shop.
I drilled every hole
with a crank drill.
It was quite a challenge.
This is my bench for doing
all of my polishing,
as well as some layout work and
miscellaneous this and that.
So while I'm sitting at
this bench, doing layout
or anything else,
I can just, you know,
take a look out this beautiful
view that I've got.
♪ ♪
That's pretty much
the whole tour.
Thanks for stopping by
and checking it out.